Olá será que você está colocando veneno
nas suas artérias sem saber os oito
alimentos que danificam suas artérias
são torradas e pão refrigerantes porque
tem altos níveis de açúcar e promove
resistência insulínica inflamação o
sorvete industrializado que ele é rico
em açúcar e gorduras trans que causam
inflamação e resistência a insulina a
margarina feita a partir de óleos
vegetais hidrogenados contém gorduras
artificiais conservantes estabilizantes
que são altamente danosos para as
artérias prefira a manteiga natural para
evitar congola arterial o álcool o
consumo excessivo dele eleva a
inflamação e a material afeta o
equilíbrio de eletrólitos como potássio
e Magnésio e pode causar arritmias
cirrose e resistência à insulina o
consumo de fast Foods são ricos em
carboidratos refinados gorduras
hidrogenadas e sódio biscoitos e
bolachas recheadas contém conservantes
açúcares e gorduras hidrogenadas óleos
vegetais e azeites de má qualidade são
ricos em acido Lino leico ômega-6 que de
forma desequilibrada pode piorar a sua
saúde arterial Não deixe de assistir o
vídeo longo relacionado o link está logo
abaixo